a quienes tengo una tabla que resume las
reacciones sm1 y sm2 lo primero que
deben tomar en cuenta es la
clasificación de la loro de alquilo si
es un alumno de alquilo primario siempre
reaccionará en un mecanismo por la vía
sn 2 los mecanismos sn dos necesitan
baja dificultad estética para que el
núcleo filo pueda atacar así que los
saludos de alquilo primarios no
reaccionan en un mecanismo por la vía sn
1 porque en esta vía se forma un kart
vocación y un kart vocación primario no
es estable por todas esas razones los
saludos de alquilo primarios tienen que
ser por sn 2 los saludos de alc y los
secundarios pueden reaccionar tanto por
sn 2 como por s n 1 pero también depende
del núcleo filo y el solvente si se
tiene un núcleo filo fuerte y un
solvente polar apro tico vimos que los
solventes apro ticos
favorecen los mecanismos por la vía sn 2
y si tenemos un núcleo filo
relativamente débil con un solvente
polar práctico entonces se favorecerá el
mecanismo sn 1 ahora los saludos de
alquilo terciarios siempre serán sn 1
porque estos saludos producen carbó
cationes terciarios que son muy estables
así que los mecanismos sn 2 no ocurren
para los alumnos de alquilo terciarios
porque hay mucha dificultad estética muy
bien hagamos algunos ejemplos empecemos
con un alumno de alquilo sencillo y lo
haremos reaccionar con agua también
calentaremos
lo primero que hay que hacer es
clasificar al alumno de alquilo este
carbono está unido al bromo y a otro
carbono así que es un alumno de alquilo
primario y los saludos de alquilo
primarios siempre reaccionan en un
mecanismo por la vía sn 2 que como ya
sabemos es un mecanismo concertado ahora
cuál es el núcleo filo bueno el agua es
el núcleo filo en esta reacción y
también es el solvente esta es una
reacción de sol policies tal vez se
confundan con esto porque el agua es un
núcleo filo relativamente débil y es
polar práctico quizás se pregunten por
qué se lleva a cabo en un mecanismo por
la vía sn 2 bueno todo depende de la
estructura de la luz de alquilo entonces
aunque el agua sea un solvente polar pro
tico que favorece al sn
esta molécula al ser un alumno de
alquilo primario solo puede reaccionar
en un mecanismo por la vía sn 2 aunque
la reacción ocurra lentamente sabemos
que el primer paso es que nuestro núcleo
filo atacara al carbono con la carga
parcial positiva justo aquí y al mismo
tiempo estos electrones se irán junto
con el grupo saliente la molécula de
agua se añade a nuestra molécula
original así el oxígeno aún tiene un par
de electrones libres pero tiene una
carga formal positiva que otra cosa
ocurre bueno otra molécula de agua entra
al mecanismo y en lugar de actuar como
un núcleo filo
esta vez funcionará como una base para
deshacernos de la carga positiva en el
oxígeno este par de electrones tomará
este protón
y así estos electrones del enlace se
quedarán con el oxígeno y finalmente
nuestro producto es el etanol
afortunadamente no tenemos que
preocuparnos por la stereo química en
esta reacción no hay centros finales así
que el etanol es nuestro único producto
hay que enfocarse en el alumno de
alquilo para saber qué tipo de mecanismo
se puede llevar a cabo y así poder
resolverlo tomando en cuenta las
posibilidades para la stereo química y
con eso llegará el producto final si
toman en cuenta estos pasos les será más
fácil veamos otro ejemplo ahora tenemos
este alumno de alquilo y por aquí pondré
un bromo observen que aquí sí hay
estéreo química lo haremos reaccionar
con cianuro de sodio enea + cn - y
nuestro solvente será de mf analicemos
primero el alumno de alquilo este
carbono está conectado a otros 2
carbonos
una luro de alquilo secundario y ya
sabemos que los alumnos de alc y los
secundarios pueden reaccionar por
mecanismos s n 1 o s n 2 pero también
depende del núcleo filo y el solvente en
este caso nuestro núcleo filo es el
anuncian oro que es un núcleo filo
relativamente fuerte y nuestro solvente
es el de mf como vimos en el vídeo
anterior es un solvente polar a pro tico
entonces para un solvente volará
práctico y un núcleo filo fuerte se da
el mecanismo s n 2 eso significa que el
núcleo filo atacará al mismo tiempo que
el halógenos al este bromo se va el
bromo se encuentra de un lado de la
molécula y el cianuro ataca de lado
opuesto entonces cuando dibujamos el
producto el cianuro sustituye al
halógeno y como el halógeno esta va
hacia nosotros
el cianuro queda lejos de nosotros
porque ataca del lado contrario a donde
el bromo sale así que obtenemos una
inversión de la configuración por la vía
del mecanismo sn 2 y este será nuestro
único producto hagamos otro ejemplo con
el mismo al 1 del kilo
ok aquí tenemos al mismo alumno de
alquilo y esta vez lo haremos reaccionar
con ácido acético dibujar el ácido
acético
tenemos una luro de alquilo secundario
pero esta vez tenemos un núcleo filo
débil nuestro núcleo filo es este
oxígeno porque tiene pares de electrones
libres no es fuerte pero es la parte
práctica de un solvente
así que funcionará como el núcleo filo y
también como el solvente si regresamos a
la tabla cuando tenemos un solvente
polar práctico y un núcleo filo débil
entonces reaccionará por el mecanismo sn
sabemos que el primer paso es la
formación del carbó catión entonces
estos electrones se irán con el bromo
para formar nuestro carbó catión
este carbono termina con una carga
formal positiva será un kart vocación
secundario y los carbó cationes
secundarios tienen la posibilidad de
reabrir los pero en este caso no
ocurrirá así que se quedará como un kart
boca tienen secundario pero siempre
tomen en cuenta los posibles reglas en
los mecanismos por la vía sn 1 entonces
tenemos un kart vocación secundario y es
cuando el núcleo filo podrá atacar un
par de electrones libres atacará justo
aquí dibujaré directamente los productos
perdemos un protón después de que ocurre
el ataque y nos queda esta molécula
como es un mecanismo sn uno el oxígeno
puede atacar por arriba o por abajo de
este carbó catión así que obtendremos
una mezcla de retención de la
configuración y de inversión de la
configuración entonces el oxígeno puede
atacar por arriba o por abajo si ataca
por este lado el oxígeno quedará hacia
nosotros y el resto de la molécula
quedará así
para ahorrar tiempo ya he sacado el
protón del mecanismo éste es un posible
producto ahora el otro posible producto
es que el oxígeno quede lejos de
nosotros atacó el kart vocaciòn por el
otro lado así nos quedan nuestros dos
posibles productos si los observamos con
cuidado este de aquí por la cuña es el
producto con la retención de la
configuración y este producto es el de
la inversión la inversión es más
probable que la retención ahora estas
dos moléculas resultan ser enantiómero
es muy importante pensar en los centros
finales cuando empezamos con un carbono
quiral como reactivo porque terminamos
con un carbono quiral como producto ya
hicimos un ejemplo del mecanismo sn 2
donde solamente obtenemos la inversión
de la configuración
hicimos un ejemplo para el mecanismo s n
1 donde obtuvimos un producto con la
inversión de la configuración y un
producto con retención de la
configuración después del ataque núcleo
físico muy bien hagamos uno más ahora
tenemos este al 1 del kilo
pondré un yodo por aquí
y lo haremos reaccionar con metanol ch3
o h
qué tipo de haluro de alquilo tenemos
ahora este carbono está unido a 123
carbonos así que es un alumno de alquilo
terciario veamos nuevamente la tabla
para un alumno de alquilo terciario solo
puede ocurrir un mecanismo sn uno bueno
lo primero que ocurre es la formación
del kart vocación así que estos
electrones se irán con el yodo y así se
forma un kart vocación terciario
es muy estable el siguiente paso es el
ataque núcleo físico verdad este par de
electrones del metanol atacará justo
aquí y claro el oxígeno sigue unido al
carbono ch3 y al hidrógeno
por acá tenemos el grupo metilo y hay un
par de electrones libres en el oxígeno
tiene una carga formal positiva en el
último paso del mecanismo otra molécula
de metanol aparece y actuará como una
base tomará a este protón y dejará a los
electrones que se quedarán con el
oxígeno finalmente nos queda nuestro
producto
este fue un mecanismo sn uno con un kart
vocación terciario muy estable y también
ocurrió una reacción ácido base al final
y no hay un centro girar en este
producto no tenemos que preocuparnos por
la estéreo química solamente obtenemos
este producto
así es como comparamos las reacciones sn
1 contra las sn 2 primero observen la
estructura de salud o de alquilo y si es
necesario tomen en cuenta al núcleo filo
y el solvente con el que se hace
reaccionar para saber qué tipo de
mecanismo necesitan lleven a cabo el
mecanismo y tomen en cuenta la estéreo
química y finalmente obtengan su
producto
si siguen estos pasos será más fácil
para ustedes